here's what would happen if everyone on  Earth farted at the same time if you  were in your bedroom and let one out or  in a park away from other people then  you'd be perfectly fine but imagine  standing on a hot crowded Subway when  suddenly the hundreds of passengers on  board each let out a giant stinker oh  you'd have hundreds of liters of  nitrogen hydrogen methane and sulfur all  crowd in the subway inhaling the smell  would be enough to make you pass out if  you're not careful the noise coming from  everyone's butt cheeks would actually  make your ears ring now sure there might  be some deaths and injuries from the  gases and volume of the farts but the  vast majority of the people on Earth  would be fine eventually the gases would  dissipate and life would get back to  normal and all the gases we let loose  wouldn't harm the planet either so all  in all this would be a smelly loud and  gross event but that's about it  so